alta vista und xp
es geht es um herz willkommen zu einem
neuen video ich bin also der mutter zu
bringen
die spiele heute richtig oder hara das
klingt so hier in dieser hand haben wir
eine ganze deutsche wir haben
körperteile auf zettel geschrieben
gesprächen wird man den körper hatte
geschrieben
ach so leute wie haben körperteile auf
zeile geschrieben die sind jetzt hier
sind was wir jetzt machen es wird sie
jeweils 111 auf der einen seite ist da
noch steht der eine dem anderen elbe
frage wenn der andere die frage richtig
beantwortet trägt der verein stelle das
körperteil das auf den cent hat wenn ich
meine falsch machen so bringt der in
keinem fall verhalten hast dein körper
teil komplett nach kompletter an ich als
er komplett an das ganze thema in der
kechika verteile und vierteilen an du
ziehst okay geben ja nur meine uhr ach
so jetzt könnte dabei ist nicht nur dann
gehe ich einfach für skripte jetzt weiß
ich auch wie hoch ist der eiffelturm in
metern zehn meter abweichungen schon
okay sonst falsch
jetzt endlich beweisen ich hab da sich
die zahl im kopf oder ich glaube ist
dann 263 meter bis 300 doch jeder hat da
ist dann will ich dich einmal gesehen
metern anleihen sind auch schon krass
oder nein das ist vorschrift für
sonderschüler
hier waren gezwungen wird und es geht
jetzt um das folgende körper zu am
unterarm ganze abend gab es geht und
mitunter haben auf die frage aus wie
heißt der längste fluss von italiens der
längste fluss von italien ich kann genau
ein tränchen flossen pro das richtig das
heißt es nochmal nein doch das haben wir
nie gesagt dort das war als er italien
ist nicht der punkt
freude ist
nein das habe ich gesagt die leute haben
und die frage richtig beantwortet japan
stelle als körperteil das auf dem zettel
hatte
diesmal gilt nicht so viel also was soll
der mist geburtig wird klar du weißt du
doch gar nicht wählen
[Musik]
schild alter boss das ganze ja
wenigstens einmal normal zumal in der
schule einfach dass wir überhaupt kein
verbraucht nicht zu rechnen ist ich will
nicht mehr durch ja aber nicht nur
da kann ich meine belange haben nicht
auf macht einfach genau das autofähre
frage dann hatten wir die ersten 40
stellen ob er aus wenn es mich kicken
oder ok die freiwillig ist was ist der
höchste berg der welt wieder ist der
höchste berg der welt und ich weiß jetzt
werden wir uns einmal sagen dass ich
wieder falsch klingen irgendwie trick
frage ist weiter geht's aber total nicht
beim comeback die höhe reißt und ich
diesen pulli benennen kann müssen also
dem tibetanischen nahmen dann bist du es
beurteilen kann komplizierte
durchgemacht hat wichtig die muschel
kommunizieren würde jetzt die hose weiß
nicht was ich jetzt an oder was also für
das 1
[Musik]
wie kann das denn passieren im gegensatz
zu dem ich hätte ja nur berichte
wahrscheinlich enthalten so glaube ich
da muss entgegen jetzt komme ich mit
demut richtung war der tag von die
maxima und ich habe kann ich darauf
geachtet wie die wuchsrichtung von
meiner haben wissenswert also ich habe
doch eine richtig harte aufgeschrieben
und ja aber er findet nicht folgen
sondern was wir so nah am wald schon
okay
nennt mir die zweite amtssprache in
uganda was ist los wirst du es heißt
kann das programm sagen die erste
ansprache ist eng mit der ersten echten
wirtschaft dann ist die zweite sprache
keine ahnung ich bessere nochmaligen
sprechen
was ist zwar schade das ist ja schon mal
ich habe ein kleines dann ist es halt
vorbei thomas kamm vom rand ja also ich
mach es bei dir mal was das ist ja eine
miese frage alter da ist nichts abgang
kommt man gar nicht okay du hast noch
einen dritten akt
du kannst jetzt machen oder eine stelle
tätig war kein ausruhen darf noch einmal
versuchen hertha-keeper gezogen
ja ok ja was eigentlich
das ist immer noch nicht mal die kerne
wieder live zu präsentieren
eigentlich sollte aufhören und einfach
weggewesen
sie war es großartig wenn ich gerade
schon ist alles richtig angetan war okay
das wäre nicht hier seht ihr das
schreiben hier oben wo so leicht und
ohne herrchen okay sagen straße in köln
hohe straße
er wohnt in der hohen straße 23 das
müsste in kaufhof seien kaufhof nein
dass das in geschäftsstraßen weiß was
ich stelle die frage aber auf jeden fall
auch fehler welcher fluss führt am
zweitmeisten wasser in deutschland es
wäre also fühlt am meisten wasser ist
schwierig wenn man es auf die länge
gehen dann würde ich schon sagen dass
die donau ist am zweitmeisten haben wir
gesagt dann also der reihe ist wenn der
egoisten aber dann ist es schon mal
passieren dass ziemlich bald die mosel
ist aber ziemlich bereits niveau pass
auch noch das ist eine der für den fall
dass wir zu sagen was ist das die donau
hatte ich doch gesagt du ich habe das
zuerst gesagt sogar aber dass dort
eingeloggt hat einen doktor ich
natürlich mehr gedanken dazu machen ob
man nicht nicht genau bekannte ich habe
[Musik]
leute das war's von rewe daran meine
haare zu entfernen
das mitmachen babys oberschenkel schönes
draus
hier können dann kam mir kommt es
infolge von was das geht und wie